hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tara Jessa and today I went
and saw Greta I over drew my lips
because Chloe something grace Chloe
grace Moretz the lead in this movie and
I'm jealous of her giant luscious lips
and also her career
I saw no hype for this movie before
today but the trailer looked really
engaging there were a couple options for
me to choose from to see today movie
wise and Greta was by far the one that
compelled me the most it looks like a
thriller horror it looked like there was
some awesome acting some awesome Platt
points then I found out that it's one of
those where they show all of the amazing
parts in the trailer all of the
thrilling action moments which there
were a few really cool ones all were
shown in the trailer every single one of
them other than a couple thrilling
moments in this movie and and a couple
really genuinely creepy even on the
verge of being scary moments a couple
sprinkled throughout other than those
this was a pretty dull movie which is
weird because it it's kind of really
cool premise and I love the story the
overall story
but I think that the writing was
terrible there's one character Chloe's
friend who she lives in New York with
and this giant penthouse suite that her
father bought for her okay and she is so
poorly written it's bonkers it's
absolutely crazy she says the most
cringe lines ever this city is gonna eat
you alive
did I just snort crystal meth or did you
just tell an old woman you'd go dog
shopping with her do you want asparagus
juice shot up your ass like this we'll
get into the writing later Greta Greta
is about Chloe's character Francis who
moves to New York with a friend I don't
know what her name is
I'll be quite honest with you
and meets Greta finds her bag on a
subway goes and takes the bag back to
her house becomes friends with her finds
out that she's a little bonkers and then
Greta starts stalking her and it's a
thriller about an old woman chasing a
young able-bodied there's a few scenes
with correct shapes in Khloe's character
Francis and I'm just like all you have
to do is just a swift kick to the groin
or just like a punch to the boobs that's
all you have to do it would be very easy
and in that they wrote Khloe's character
Francis to be very timid very innocent
naive dumb she moved to New York and her
friends I go it's gonna eat you up and
it's like okay well thank you for that
exposition I guess because everything
that Chloe does as this character which
must be directed Torrio directed that
way it's the term everything she does is
so timid and so I'm just a small tool am
it me timid dear Bambi who I think the
story itself is a really cool idea I
think that they make this woman who
desperately needs a daughter and a
friend and someone should control and
manipulate and and then it turns into
something scary at the end I think
that's really cool but the way that it's
pasted and done is not well executed
right up front because Francis is such a
timid character she's terrified of Greta
right after she learns that Greta is
kind of manipulating her very much
manipulating her and she's just
immediately terrified and she hasn't
really done anything
definitely she should be cautious of
this woman but she hasn't like shown any
kind of aggression or anything other
than like desperately needing a friend
and she makes this switch it's like
terrified of this woman and then so of
course it ends up that she should be
terrified of her good instincts I guess
but it's just it the switch is too
quickly I'll tell ya when she needs to
be
and it's this the bubble that Shoei I'm
seeing I need to find that I think maybe
it's compelling to me because I could
totally see myself getting into this
situation like being overly friendly to
someone who clearly needs that in their
life and then getting pulled into
dinners and events and hanging out with
and then finding out that they're a
little much and then like will still not
pump in the brakes on the relationship
kind of deal I could see that happening
and so I don't know I think a lot of
people can identify with that and being
a little maybe - not drawing any
boundaries I guess but there's just
moments where the character of Francis
is poorly written the the friend is just
a mess just a mess Greta is compellingly
written and acted I think she was
probably my favorite actors in this
Chloe I really enjoy her a lot but I
don't think that it must actually it's
probably the writing or something
something was a little off there I just
think that it was pretty boring reacted
boringly written boringly paced and
there's some really cool compelling
scenes right in the third act and then
it's done with a terrible ending we get
this really cool like escape scene and
and then it's just bad the best friend
comes in and tries to act like a badass
you need a doctor and I need my friend
okay
pump the brakes the asparagus juice pump
the brakes there's a lot of character
choices that don't make any sense at all
like she's clearly asking for help
Francis when things get a little dicey
with Greta and a lot of people just
don't take her seriously the police
don't take her seriously which sure
you're in New York City and this woman
is following you again punch her in the
boobs but her boss is awful Greta shows
up at Francis's work and Francis goes to
her boss and is like hey I don't want to
talk to that woman could you maybe just
get rid of her and he's like you get rid
of her I'm not your public relations
person and like that's just not
believable
that's not knowing that that's
unbelievable it's not believable I
didn't believe it at all in the moment
also a bit later Greta shows up at work
again and one of her co-workers is like
isn't your stalker and friends this is
like yeah
she's like good luck bitch about this
well it clearly a distress
does it make sense it felt unreal it did
not feel believable at all in the
writing there's a lot of bad like
exposition you find out very early on
very quickly that Chloe's mother has
died and then you find out that the dad
has moved on and just like chunks of
exposition through dialogue and it it's
not well done it's not compelling really
going in hard on this movie I had some
good chuckles at the characters being
terrified of an old lady cheesy but one
really good thing that I absolutely
loved was the music the music made this
otherwise pretty dull film into a more
thrilling thriller if you can call it
that there's also a really cool sequence
of a fake-out and I loved that part it
was really cool it's like this is the
movie that I wanted to see in this one
like five six minutes show and then
everything after that I'm gonna get into
some massive spoilers right now I think
the six people that were planning on
seeing this film should maybe click off
now but she gets captured by Greta
Francis gets captured by Greta and there
are so many moments where she can escape
and she doesn't she's this able-bodied
young woman I know she's tented we've
seen it we get that she's timid but
you're you're in this murderers house
get this yeah the ending is terrible
other than a few memorable thrilling
moments that are very few and far
between and way to you shorts this is a
pretty pretty big flop for me it's not
gonna be remembered I don't think it's a
note from me I don't often go in so hard
against things but this was just it was
there's clear errors coming from me
someone who doesn't know what they're
talking about that's how you know again
I really like
as an actress I really think that the
actors who played Greta I know I've seen
her and a bunch of stuff but I forget
she was really really good there were
some really cool sequences and I think
the overall idea of the story was really
cool I just think that it wasn't overall
executed very well at all
pretend I'm Chloe I have a round face
and big lips - hi I'm Chloe
I have an awesome career and I'm super
cool thank you so much for watching I
will see you all next week
with oh damn Captain Marvel is nice
sweet alright see you next week with
Captain Marvel
I'm like chewing gum I tend to stick
around that's a really great line also
who removes chewing gum without peanut
butter or mayonnaise or something just
your fingers that's not gonna work
you
[Music]